where you from I'm from New York I want
to we move from New York remove you from
New York move the content from cocktail
moved to Long Beach and I went to Long
Beach Poly along like I say I have two
kids three kids two girls and three boys
single parent and she passed away and
you know this I have two kids I have a
boy a girl
my sister has none my brother have one
and you know this is a normal family and
you're at your own right here
yeah I'm not alone I got family out here
that Oh Deb you okay so I'm actually
need to say she was cool that's cool so
you're you're living on the sidewalk by
now innit in until my partner what are
you doing for money I got I'm SSI myself
plus if I don't keep cousin but I'm OS
as I and I'm my own pain and I do right
here and then I do here for a little
yeah
and then and then I just do point O so
or you depart so he's doing that too so
that's a lot of money he's a super nose
and I stopped doing that because I had
my kids where are your kids huh you know
in New York for my sister
you've everybody here to doing one
driver to some source so it starts off
so you know if I smoke crack it isn't
murder but we all but we'd all don't
bother nobody we call mine own business
y'all take care of each other don't get
along all y'all from the Mexicans to the
blacks for the Asian to the Chinese we
all get home my dad is Asian so what
makes a little Asian toast yeah okay his
name is Lee Taylor he's mixed with East
Asian so well to to agree dissolve big
family wait your mom I swear she been
gone a long time like I thought I had my
daughter she was around they're not
they're my son she was still around so
she just mmm all long time ago we don't
put her in the wall
and what age were you and you thought oh
I was 17 17 unique and we're down here
and I came back I'm going back home now
I came back home I was pregnant
yeah how many years ago zero huh how
many years you guys hear us since I was
17 that's actually 17 years going all-in
on that dog
I've been down since I was 17 what'd you
do I go to Mission or selfless the
Oracle pen hell I'll do whatever I gotta
do to eat yeah I would fiance he goes
there and hustle you do whatever you
gotta do to us a survivor
what you like to see happen for you the
next five years I would love to see me
and my fiance and my happy kids in a
nice little house
what's crazy story to seen out here I
don't saw a lobby would be killed I saw
my best friend trying to get dragged
downstream
dragged out my car in the car yeah my
best friend trying out house I get
literally down drag down Street Oh dope
dealers dragged her down the street and
I saw it with my own eyes
attached to the car yeah she was under
the car she was just the guy the curtain
of guys running the guy was a lady she
went to the lady against the lady
grabbed our money back in grab the dough
and dragged it up Street in killer
and then my best friend my husband
homeboy he got killed in his team he got
killed I he came out of this thing it
was for the police and he was fighting
and he the police shot him seven times
one of the year one in the chest he
dynasty diamond bhai as to their mother
homeboy he died is stamped by the car
man yells that's me how was your
brother's day didn't work out
well I will he wanted to do is see my
kids and I didn't get to see you
cuz you think like that ha got the black
guy I got into a fight what it do women
like me do not need to get in no fights
special with nobody you get fired boil
over stupid stuff stupid stuff it's
seriously we were we think we might
smoke we might have fun my duty is we
might do that but still a woman should
not get hit by no me so I'll tell you
I'll put through hell I've been through
out I can't I can't complain I see these
people down there every day tired
I wish I could share like I said wish I
could share stuff I don't care
I'll go to school I'm a good parent
okay nobody said nothing bad about me
and I help people everyday I tried to
like I said I've been down here since I
was 17 I wish I could change your work
no I don't do hey don't be easy but you
know stage guys to me let me tell you
about that whole not that not that
I could tell you okay I love this down
in the stomach you didn't start yeah
everybody's guys yeah I was this much
pregnant
six month program you go stab and I had
our wait
I'm askin do
I made my mouth covered up and on it
yeah my best I like ice on my best
friend gets down I saw my best friend
get dragged down the street you know my
homeboy got killed in his tent by a cop
so he got stabbed
I was bleeding in the inside but my
daughter came my daughter then gosh she
was alive not the habit or but they had
to stitch me up cuz I was stabbed well
bad you delivery right there they're
under living her right in there yeah and
not in the hospital either I deliver her
own streets thank you know in a hotel
my homeboy told me I put up on the
inside me
we hit the pipe and I had our early
labor
I didn't feel no pain I didn't feel
nothing I looked down and my daughter
were young she's okay
yeah she's eight years old today
now just eight years old
look at these women now that is pregnant
but
why which I'm gonna be down here
pregnant you know I mean I have stories
I've been through it and I now see now
what I would do
won't make it think I want to sit here
watch other people go through
boyfriend's beating him up body pregnant
you know what I mean
my homegirl got kicked he sucked in the
stomach right somebody cuz she didn't
want to do it and he told her to do
soccer and thus turned and her baby fell
out one hand missing one eye one nose
and forth from you and three minutes and
half of her head
the baby the baby is informed baby
inside Italy in the park
they had to park light to close the park
down the until they got that baby out of
there totally the baby felt inside the
toilet it was a all baby but the eyes
missing nose suck the phone the face
little smoked ears and smooth on hands
fingers feet huh deform you hands feet
missing
so you tell me hi is downtown ain't
nothing out here for people to be on
you